bonjour bonjour a tous voila moi je me
présente
hadrien g j'ai créé une société qui
s'appelle de moustache il ya quatre ans
et vous nous présenter rapidement en
fait on produit des vidéos d'humour
qu'on diffuse après sûr sur youtube sur
les réseaux sociaux sur le web en
général et donc en fait qu'on a créé
cette société il ya trois ans et demi on
s'est dit on va faire en fait pour que
partant de rien parce qu'on a on
n'existait pas quand est ce qu'on va
faire pour que pour que les gens voient
nos vidéos comment ce qu'on va faire
pour faire peut-être des milliers de
vues ou de choses comme ça et c'était
assez compliqué parce que si vous voyez
un petit peu comment fonctionne
l'univers de youtube
c'est la plus grosse plateforme de vidéo
dans le monde il ya des contenus qui
sont pleut des en permanence c'est des
chiffres qui sont absolument incroyable
en fait en termes de volumes de contenu
c'est un univers extrêmement
concurrentiel et moi je venais de la de
la télévision j'ai traîné pendant
quelques années chez chez m6 notamment
du côté des programmes courts fabriquer
des programmes courts comme camelot
caméra cachée donc on avait l'habitude
d'écrire des petits sketchs et un peu
marrant mais là la question est un peu
différente c'était comment faire pour
que appartement où je mets ces contenus
en ligne
les gens soient au courant de ça soit
averti deux de ses contenus qu'ils les
regardent que s'il est partagé tout ça
et donc c'est mon sujet d'aujourd'hui en
fait c'est j'essaie de vous expliquer
après trois ans d'expérimentation ben ce
qui peut être le ski peut faire le
succès d'une vidéo sur youtube
c'est un sujet assez étroit mais plus
globalement comment comment communiquer
sur les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui pour
votre message soit entendu et repris et
nous on a procédé un petit peu par
l'expérimentation c'est à dire qu'on a
mis trois quatre vidéos au départ la
première a pas du tout marché la
deuxième a pas du tout le marché et donc
on sait commencer à se faire du souci
parce que on avait prévu je serai dans
le business plan de faire je crois à
50000 vu par vidéo là ça faisait
pas de chiffre dérisoire et la troisième
vidéo assez un million de vues en 72
heures à peu près et donc on s'est dit
mais qu'est-ce qui s'est même se
produire par rapport aux autres alors en
l'occurrence elle est un peu
particulière celle ci parce qu'elle
traitait mêlant mauvais rustique de la
masturbation et de ses conséquences
donc on s'est dit il ya peut-être un
facteur a décoré les en terme
d'enseignements par rapport au reste
mais néanmoins alors après on a remis
d'autres et puis ça ça moyennement
marché puis ça recommence on a fait une
autre qu'elle fait un million de vues à
peu près dans le même temps et donc on
s'est dit bon il ya peut-être un certain
nombre d'enseignements à tirer c'est ça
dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui on
a dégagé trois principes qui sont pas
une recette magistère con
malheureusement on n'a pas compris
à date comment faire un blockbuster
comment faire un énorme succès sont sais
pas mais on a repéré trois critères
vingt trois choses communes dans un
succès sur youtube et plus généralement
sur le web en général et donc ça je vous
parlais il ya trois idées la première
c'est que l'expert et l'expérience nous
fait du contenu sur le web la manière
dont vous le consommer non vous le
découvrez est très particulière par
rapport à d'autres expériences de
contenu la deuxième idée c'est que vous
adresser une communauté ce qui est une
notion un petit peu différente par
exemple de l'audience en télévision moi
je n'ai la télé et j'ai mis un petit peu
de temps à comprendre la différence avec
ce que c'est qu'une communauté comment
elle se construit comme mort comme elle
fonctionne et la troisième idée c'est
que et cela va de soi c'est que si vous
voulez faire un succès de communication
sur le web aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut que les gens partagent
votre contenu parce qu'il n'ya pas de
partage vous êtes en fait du coup
naturellement limité à votre audience
naturel qui est forcément restreinte
donc là la première est la suivante on
essaie toujours nous quand on fabrique
un contenu et qu'on ne publie de se
demander dans quel contexte les gens
vont le découvrir et le regarder le
consommer et à ce titre ce titre là moi
je voudrais vous poser différentes
expériences de consommation d'un contenu
culturel artistique ou de divertissement
par exemple là aujourd'hui
ted vous venez c'est une démarche
consciente
vous faites un effort particulier vous
avez prévu de le faire si je le pousse
un petit peu plus loin dans ce genre
d'expérience si vous décidez d'aller à
l'opéra par exemple il ya peut-être des
fans de wagner dans la salle si vous
voulez aller à beyrouth
c'est toute une démarche ça prend
beaucoup de temps avant d'avoir une
place ça coûte assez cher même très cher
il faut se déplacer là-bas vous habiller
pour l'occasion vous installer dans la
salle donc vous êtes dans une
disposition d'esprit extrêmement
réceptifs pour voir un contenu ce qui
fait que vous êtes vous avez un niveau
de tolérance et d'attention qui est très
très élevé je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué que les les portables notamment
créé chez la plupart d'entre nous un
déficit d'attention de plus en plus on
se lasse de plus en plus vite des choses
mais quand vous avez fait la démarche de
choisir un contenu et de le voir vous
avez une plus grande attention et nous
on se dit à linverse quand on publier un
contenu sur youtube c'est peut-être la
pire des expériences de consommation
possible pour un contenu c'est à dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui vous dit à
l'arrêt de bus tu iras tu as vu cette
vidéo c'est marrant non ce nul et du
coup on si c'est ça la le cas à peu près
générale dans lequel les gens ont
découvert nos contenus sur lequel on a
nous pas mal bossé et pas mal investi
alors les premières secondes
même avant même que le contenu est
commencé tout ça est fondamentale le
titre je sais pas si vous avez en tête
avant que les titres que vous pouvez
trouver sur les sollicitent comme yahoo
ou le huffington post ou de buzzfeed ou
le même si le sujet n'est pas très
intéressant la manière dont ces tournées
vous donne envie de cliquer alors même
que vous savez que ça c'est privé vous
avez déçu ce que vous avez trouvé comme
réponse
la vignette c'est à dire le la le dessin
con mais qu'on met dessus la photo gêne
explique l'aïe viennent de rendre
publique une étude qui raconte en fait
que chez netflix en fait ils bêta test
en permanence les vignettes sur lequel
vous avez cliqué pour voir quelles sont
celles qui entraînent le plus haut taux
de clic
ils ont découvert que par exemple - il
ya deux personnages sur une vignette
plus on clique plus les personnages on
est un méchant plus on clique alors que
vous en l'air sa part - clic donc c'est
une bonne année gothique bah oui mais du
coup ça entraîne une plus grande
consommation de contenus et là on n'est
même pas encore rentré dans le contenu
on est prêt les premières images de la
vidéo et puis après il ya les premières
images qui arrivent et je sais pas si
vous avez en tête par exemple les
publicités pour les voitures il ya une
espèce de lieux communs quand on fait
une pub pour les voitures c'est vous
prenez un paysage écossais brumeux
magnifique puis à une très très belle
voiture qui serpente au loin comme ça
sur fond de musique symphonique
alors ça c'est super en télé mais si
vous faites ça sur youtube il ya un
problème on
mental c'est quand en bas de l'écran à
droite et a marqué vous pouvez skippé
cette publicité dans 5 secondes avec un
décompte et tout est donc vous dites
vous êtes connus ont focalisé sur le
fait que dans deux secondes vous allez
pouvoir vous débarrasser de la publicité
et du coup ne te conseille quand on
travaille comme agence de pub dit bah en
fait vous allez 5 secondes pour
convaincre les gens de ne pas faire ça
et donc les espèces de rythme un petit
peu particulier à youtube et c'est ce
sur quoi je voulais attirer votre
attention c'est en fait on a une sorte
de temporalité relatives au contenu
trois minutes à l'opéra sais rien trois
minutes autant youtube enfin ça paraît
une éternité
j'ai montré un exemple d'une vidéo
typique
ça c'est un gros gros succès sur youtube
juste pour attirer votre attention sur
le rythme avec lequel il va raconter son
histoire
en réalité si je pouvais y avait plus de
sous marins visibles ou pas il voulait à
l'est j'adore le lait parce que l'autre
fois devant la ruche marche est
tranquille et l'état de droit
c'est pas méchant ce que je te lula et
les fouilles c'est typique d'une des
youtube ça va très vite
les gens les plus connus sur youtube en
france c'est norman et cyprien et si
vous regarder leurs vidéos qu'on appelle
des podcasts en fait il sait comme un
peu du stand-up vous raconter une blague
et ça a l'air assez cool en fait quand
vous regardez le rythme et mais en
réalité c'est très rapide parce que au
moment même où ils ont fait la blague il
passe à autre chose et si vous le
comparez avec ce qu'on fait en
télévision par exemple dans les guignols
de l'info il y avait avant une séquence
typique c'était la séquence de
l'interview donc avait pbd qui recevait
quelqu'un à côté de lui et il y avait
une blague en général c'était la même
blague tiré pendant une minute trente
doucement mais c'était le temps télé en
fait alors que sur internet une minute
trente sur la même blague c'est aberrant
fait on des enduits de mombasa et j'ai
compris se passe à autre chose
dans le pire des cas si j'ai pas compris
je reviens en arrière je le regarde à
nouveau donc ya pas la même temporalité
ça c'était mon premier point c'est à
dire de faire attention à avoir cette
notion
de rythme et de formats et est appliqué
sa la plupart ddd message qu'on veut pas
c'est que ce soit une vidéo un tweet un
article la forme contre aujourd'hui il
ya une une société d'information qui est
en train d'exploser sur facebook s'est
agi plus pour al jazeera plus ils font
des vidéos en fait qu'ils peuvent se
consommer sans le son poste table sur le
player de facebook et qu'il faut moins
d'une minute et naturellement ça explose
parce que c'est très très facile à
contrôler mon deuxième point ces deux
devient en fait les on s'adresse pas en
fait quand on peut lui un contenu sur
internet à une audience a en particulier
parce que si vous faites un journal
télévisé par exemple vous savez vous
avez 3 4 personnes vous regardez mes un
moment précis et que c'est des gens qui
sont pas cons pas forcément de point en
commun ils ont décidé de regarder votre
chaîne plutôt qu'une autre
mais la différence avec internet section
internet les gens se construisent en
communauté et alors
la définition que nous on donne à une
communauté c'est la suivante c'est
l'ensemble des gens qui se mobilisent
autour des valeurs de votre marque
quand je démarre que ça veut dire une
marque d'annonceurs un média un individu
mais quelqu'un ou quelque chose
identifiez autour d'un certain nombre de
valeurs et dans ces valeurs là les gens
vont agir de manière plus ou moins forte
autour de votre marque et les gens vont
par exemple adoré ce que vous faites y
en a qui vont être intéressés il y en a
tous qu'ils vont trouver ça nul
il y en a qui vont vous voyez et puis
une grosse majorité de femmes
et puis il ya les 1 2 3 4 % de fans
hardcore de ce que vous faites et ces
gens là c'est très intéressant parce que
avec avec internet vous pouvez les
identifier de manière très précise sur
youtube par exemple nous on utilise une
fonctionnalité qui s'appelle top fans et
qui nous permet de voir quels sont les
gens qui ont le plus d'interactions avec
notre marque qui se partagent le plus
qu'ils aiment le plus content qu'ils
font plus de commentaires qualitative
par rapport à ce qu'on fait donc on peut
savoir qui c'est on peut avoir des
informations sur quel est leur profil et
on peut communiquer avec eux c'est à
dire qu'on peut aller voir directement
les gens qui sont le plus concernés par
ce qu'on raconte
et ça c'est intéressant parce que du
coup si on entretient un dialogue avec
avec cette communauté la très forts ils
peuvent devenir des ambassadeurs de
votre marque
devenir le relais de ce que ce que vous
dites on a coutume de dire sur internet
que la balance de la communication
fonctionne c'est que je parle enfin une
personne parle allant voir son message à
une audience l'audience réponse sauf si
c'est vraiment pas du tout intéressant
si l'audience vous réponds bah vous a
privé vous devez lui répondre à nouveau
c'est ça le connaît evans john tu es si
vous créer les conditions nécessaires à
ce que ça se produise
normalement la halle à l'audience et la
communauté vont se mettre va se mettre à
parler entre eux soit c'est ce qu'on
appelle le liseur gentle comme tête et
quand ça ça se produit c'est un impact
qui monstrueux parce que tout d'un coup
bas olano efforts naturel les gens vont
s'emparer de votre contenu
ils m'ont commencé à créer des méta
contenu des parodies des détournements
vont prendre votre message et le porter
le plus loin possible
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle un buzz
concrètement c'est quand ce genre de
chose se produit nous on l'a vécu
quelques fois avec nous avec notre
marque en effet une vidéo
vous avez peut-être vu en novembre
autour de la coop 21 on s'était engagés
pour soutenir nicolas hulot autour des
thématiques climatique et les gens se
sont positionnés je pense non pas à
cause de la qualité de la vidéo mais
parce que ça leur parlait et ils ont pu
se réapproprier un message assez simple
qui est de dire on se sent concerné par
le sens de notre planète du coup mon
point est le suivant si le contenu ou le
message que voulait porter peut être
approprié par les gens ils peuvent se
l'approprier en faire quelque chose à
leur manière tout d'un coup ça peut
devenir un tremblement fort du coup je
voulais prendre cet exemple la bouche
minutes vous savez de quoi il s'agit il
s'agit d'une image du dernier star wars
et cette image à être dans la
bande-annonce dans le trailer qui était
en avril 2015 ou en mai 2004 situe pas
de bêtises et cette image là a fait le
tour du web
simplement parce que le méchant à un
sabre laser avec une croix une sorte de
garde sur les côtés me dire c'est
anecdotique ce genre de choses mais par
ben papa dans l'univers de star wars où
les gens comme moi qui sont des gros
gros fans se disent c'est une innovation
majeure qui changent la face de
l'humanité et du coup les gens en
parlent et donc ils font ça par exemple
où ça
ou encore ça je sais pas je suis pas en
train de dire ça beaucoup d'intérêt mais
c'est génère une conversation triche et
donc il ya des trucs en fait pour
générer ça un des trucs les plus connus
nous on essaie de le faire assez
systématiquement ce qu'on appelle les
easter egg en français au de pâques
c'est à dire c'est les petits détails
cachés dans votre contenu que les 1% de
tarés vont voir et ils vont être
tellement contents de les découvrir
qu'ils vont en parler à tout le monde
parce que c'est vrai que c'est
valorisant
tout d'un coup vous découvrir un truc
incroyable bas le réflexe naturel et de
foncer vers votre copain police et j'ai
découvert tel truc et tout ça donne ce
genre de chose par exemple dans l'avant
dernier épisode de bref ce n'est la
série sur canal + mettez pas un
programme même équité fait un peu denses
état d'esprit ils ont mis une ligne de
force à l'intérieur je sais pas combien
de gens cette salle qui comprennent vers
le morse
on n'est pas de mal vais donc ce n'est
pas beaucoup en tout cas moi je le
comprends pas et la probabilité donc ça
donne ça laquelle est la probabilité que
quelqu'un s'aperçoivent qu'une ligne de
morses dans cet épisode
à la télé on va dire faible et et
combien de gens qui comprennent le mort
sont bien décoder ce message et moi par
les bains c'est arrivé il ya bien un mec
qui comprend le morse qui s'est dit
c'est génial
ils ont mis en morse c'est quoi ces
brefs messages un très bon renfort et le
mec était tellement content qu'il a
publié sur toute la toile
on se dit c'est génial c'est quelle
innovation majeure dans l'écriture du
visuel externe donc est ce assez répandu
plus en plus troisième point j arrive du
coup c'est qu'est ce qui fait que les
gens vont se partager inventé alors
je vous montre la vidéo juste après le
nom on a une théorie qui est pas
révolutionnaire non plus là dessus mais
de bon sens on se dit les gens partagent
ce en cours ils se reconnaissent de la
même manière qu'à une époque quand vous
étiez ado comme moi j'étais ado en tout
cas on se définissait un petit peu par
nos goûts musicaux dans le rock dans le
hip hop chose 0 matin j'ai même tel
groupe mais ça voulait dire quelque
chose de qui on était eh ben aujourd'hui
il ya un petit peu de ça dans la danse
que vous mettez sur votre wall ce que
vous publiez sur sur twitter ou sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire que en
publiant un contenu en relayant un
contenu va vous dites voilà voilà
comment je vois le monde
voilà ce qui me fait rire voilà ce qui
m'a touché voilà ce qui me fait ce qui
me fait marrer ou ce qui me fait peur
par exemple et plus le contenu publié
permet de susciter cet élément de
définition de sa personnalité
plus ils se partagent les choses qui ne
peut vous fait rire et vous partagerez
jamais parce que c'est l'heure
relativement honteux il ya des gens qui
t'ont qui posent des questions qui est
marrante comme ça c'est pourquoi sur les
sites pornographiques et un bouton de
partage j'espère que vous avez déjà vu
quelqu'un qui partage une vidéo de
youporn moi pas parce que ça se partage
pas et pourtant ça fait vraiment défini
sur la personnalité
donc ce que je n'ai pas complètement
vrai mais mon poing un indien mort si
vous arrivez à mettre le doigt sur
quelque chose qui qui est bien vu qui
est juste qui est dans l'air du temps
qui a un écho très fort avec ce que les
gens en tête et on voit deux de plus en
plus qu'il ya différents types
d'actualité je sais pas si vous voyez il
ya quelques années elle a les news les
aides lines et l actualité
internationale
et puis après on est passé à l'actualité
locale aujourd'hui quand vous regardez
l'ouverture de jt c'est très très très
locale est très concernant on n'est pas
loin sur à 13h sur une chaîne sur la une
de commencer en disant alors la fête de
la courge est aujourd'hui ma shakhtar
est comme vous regardez maintenant sur
facebook on est encore plus plus que
dans le local dans l'ultra concernant
c'est à dire que c'est le les gens vous
connaissez ce qui est arrivé près de
chez vous de plus en plus donc s'il
allait inscrire votre contenu dans dans
ce dance études dans un contexte
extrêmement concernant
eh ben il ya de plus en plus en plus de
chances qu'ils se partagent alors je
vais vous montrer une vidéo de cyprien
qui lui a essayé de raconter un petit
peu ce qu'ils percevaient du monde de
l'entreprise à chaque fois que je vois
une marque ou un produit
je peux pas m'empêcher de m'imaginer les
gens qui ont bossé dessus derrière en
réunion parce que parfois ils prennent
des décisions bizarres ces gens là alors
alors je m'imagine les réunions chez
ikea chez ap
mon cerveau ça donne ça les réunions
chez apple iphone et plus de pixels
on va gérer ça et match va trouver une
note de 6 jaws avec des idées de
nouveaux produits
bonjour away non c'est pas vrai du tout
l'iphone 6 iphone si c'est bien chez
microsoft
combien ne surpasse on a vendu bien
qu'on en parle comme ça chez nos coeurs
vous vous souvenez du 33-10 a eu ce
téléphone qui se vendait les choses
concernant tout le monde comprend qu'on
partage
j'arrive au terme de cette présentation
une fois encore les trois aigles enfin
les trois principes que j'ai énoncé
c'est pas des règles gravé dans le
marbre et on peut faire exactement le
contraire de ce que je vais dire à mon
avis toujours faire des gros carton sur
youtube mais mon point plus large
c'était bien dans dans le monde des
réseaux sociaux qui est en train de se
développer aujourd'hui si vous voulez
faire passer un message de communication
puissant c'est important d'avoir en tête
que la communication unilatérale
je parle j'envoie un message sans
attendre leur tour est terminé et que
maintenant il ya des gens qui peut vous
répondre
des gens qui peuvent s'approprier votre
contenu de votre parole et il est
essentiel de les prendre en compte dans
la manière dont vous allez structuré et
passer votre message
je vous remercie beaucoup pour